You know, beheadings when they happen
out in the middle of the desert uh by uh
ISIS terrorists are one thing, but when
a state like Saudi Arabia has a
beheading, you begin to wonder what's
going on. So, Robert Spencer joins us,
director of Jihad Watcher. Robert, this
is a story of a lady who had been
convicted in Saudi Arabia of both sexual
abuse and murder of her 7-year-old
stepdaughter. She was publicly beheaded.
What's up? Well, this is something that
happens not infrequently in Saudi
Arabia. Saudi Arabia, of course, is a
Sharia state. It adheres fully to
Islamic law. And that kind of crime is
considered to be causing corruption in
the land, which is punishable by death.
Beheading of course is sanctioned in the
Quran in uh two places chapter 8:12 and
chapter 47:4 and so uh they consider
themselves to be acting completely in
accord with Islamic dictates in
beheading this woman. There are actually
two ways to behead according to the
rules in Saudi Arabia. One's with
painkillers, one's not. They purposely
didn't give this lady painkillers so she
felt more pain. This is barbaric.
Yeah, there's no doubt about that. uh
this uh whole Islamic law is barbaric in
numerous ways. I mean for example I
mentioned causing corruption in the land
and chapter 5:33 of the Quran specifies
that the punishment for that can be uh
killing or crucifying or amputation of
the hand and foot on opposite sides. Uh
these are all barbaric things and uh
beheading is just is actually milder
than than some of these others. Well,
good point. But the is this a trend? I
mean, we've seen by the count that I saw
in a news report, seven so far this
year, 87 last year. Yeah, it's just part
for the course. Uh, seven this year is
quicker is is is uh more than usual, but
this is something they've always done.
It's in accord with their constitution,
with their image of themselves, with
their proclamation as being the
guardians and the truest exponents of
Islam.
These are supposed to be reasonable
people though. Um and people talk about
shar Sharia law for instance in the
finance act they talk about Sharia law
being a good thing uh and you know
conservative if you will not the case no
uh the thing about it is that these
things are not separable and when you're
talking about Sharia finance the west
has been quite hospitable to it and all
these banks international banks have
Sharia finance boards and they have
these elaborate uh uh strategiums
whereby they uh enable Muslims not to
pay interest and so on and uh these
things are all considered to be good
parts of uh good aspects of the whole
multiculturalist enterprise but the
reality is is that Sharia is one entity
and once you start accommodating it
you're just opening the door to
accommodating more of it the financial
aspects are not separable from these
punishments of amputation and beheading
and so on crucifixion that are mandated
for various crimes so the actually
especially in the finance sector is
setting a very bad precedent by
accommodating Sharia finance because
it's only opening the door to
accommodation of other aspects of Sharia
in the future and there have already
been and will be more calls for just
that in the west. I I I hadn't made that
connection but now you say it it makes
perfect sense because we just had that
case of a a guy creating a website who
gets a thousand lashes in 10 years in
jail for creating a website. Where where
is that in any uh ancient uh writings by
Muhammad? Oh, absolutely. It's uh very
much in there actually. Uh he was
considered to have insulted Islam and so
uh the Saudis are being lenient on him
by giving these thousand giving him
these thousand rashes. Uh they could
within their rights according to Islamic
law put him to death. uh just as the
Charlie Heepto cartoonists were put to
death by the gunman uh the in Paris
because they had insulted Islam. We both
consider it's just part of Islamic law.
Well, true. Your your point is
excellent. I mean, we haven't heard
Saudi Arabia speak out to the best of my
knowledge about what's happened in
France. No, what can they say? This is
this is Islamic law. This is what they
do. This is something that is in accord
with the teachings of Islam. The thing
about it is uh is that when do you have
the the these kinds of atrocities, the
common response from Saudi Arabia, from
the Organization of Islamic Cooperation,
from international Islamic entities is
to call for restrictions on the freedom
of speech. They want to use the things
like the shooting in Paris to uh compel
the West, intimidate the West really
into clamping down on free expression
and criminalizing criticism of Islam.
They don't want to apologize for these
attacks. They want to uh eradicate the
cause of these attacks which is our
speaking freely. Okay. Now the thing is
Saudi Arabia has oil and you can't
exactly sanction them without cutting
off the rest of the world uh from oil.
Or can you because we currently have
sanctions against Russia? Yeah. You
know, I don't think it's impossible. I
think that it has not been done but not
because it could not be done. The Bush
family had very close ties to the
Saudis. Obama, of course, very famously
bowed to the king of Saudi Arabia. Both
administrations have shown no interest
really in pursuing the Saudi connection
to jihad terror, the Saudi propagation
of the jihad terror ideology all over
the world. And the oil connection is
just keeping us hamstrung in this way.
George W. Bush right after 9/11 should
have instituted a an allout effort to
free us from dependence on Saudi oil and
to you know offshore drilling and
pipelines and fracking everything that
could be done. It should have been done
then but it still hasn't been done now
all these years later. Yeah. And indeed
the Saudis are still pulling the strings
as far as prices are concerned. I guess
this is the source of conspiracy
theorists as much as anything else that
the Saudis were behind 9/11 for
instance. Certainly the money came from
Saudi Arabia and the wealth generated
there. There's a lot of unanswered
questions about that. I mean, of course,
everybody knows that 15 of the 19
hijackers were Saudis, but there also
all these strange things like the only
flights, the only planes in the sky on
September 12th, 2001 were taking
relatives of the Bin Laden family back
to Saudi Arabia. the uh I I had a
personal friend who was ill and he was
in the Mayo Clinic on uh in in September
2001 and he told me that the the place
was full of Saudis. There were all sorts
of Saudis there getting treatment and
the morning of the 11th he woke up and
all the Saudis had left before he turned
on the news and saw what had happened.
And then there there's this Florida
family that disappeared with food
cooking on the stove and they were
Saudis and they disappeared just on
9/11. The FBI has stonewalled about it,
resisted all uh ex explorations,
investigations of what's what actually
went on there. There's so many strange
questions that probably never will be
answered. Of course, the Saudi section
of the uh 9/11 Commission report was
redacted for years and most of it is
still secret. Robert, incredible. Thank
you. Thank you. Howard Spencer joining
us from Jiad